amina muhammad abdi was known for being
a fearless and outspoken critic of
somalia's government until she was
killed two months ago
she was an opposition mp vying for a
third term
her sister samira says she wanted to be
part of a new government that would make
somalia a fairer and safer place
a suicide bomber ran at her at an
election meeting in the town of
belladoin
the armed group al-shabab said it was
responsible
she's one of hundreds of people who've
been killed in the 10th lead up to
somalia's presidential election which
has been delayed by more than a year
[Music]
samira says she lost much more than her
sister
amina always helped everyone who came
her way whether they were her relatives
or not or from any clan she didn't care
about those things she just saw people
and humanity if anyone was in need she
just cared about the needs of that
person
since amina was killed nearly 300 mps
have been sworn in
the somalis didn't get to vote for them
they were selected by clan
representatives and officials in
processes that many say were corrupted
and rigged
mps elect the president under a system
that was introduced after the central
government collapsed in 1991.
everyone familiar with the process says
buying of votes is widespread
winning depends on forging alliances
between factions
in the days leading up to the vote many
of the deals have been discussed here at
the heavily fortified jazeera hotel in
the capital mogadishu
it's a place where politicians and their
supporters can meet in relative safety a
televised debate between four of the
most prominent candidates was planned
advertised on this billboard but it
didn't happen the candidates disagreed
on the terms and so somalis haven't even
got to hear what the policies of the
different candidates are but what people
think won't affect the outcome because
the decision lies in the hands of the
members of parliament
people familiar with the process say the
large amounts of cash involved still
don't guarantee anyone a victory or even
a vote no candidate is campaigning
without money
then
all mbs are just roaming trafficking
around telling them i vote for you and
everyone is guaranteeing voting for you
for you for you someone can make money
from five six candidates and then you
have only one vote
people here hope that completing the
elections will make somalia a little
safer
but this is a place where politicians
can't even safely move around their own
capital city
whoever wins the vote faces some
enormous challenges malcolm webb al
jazeera mogadishu somalia